welcome to our periodic table videos
this is an experiment for me just as
much as it will be for you when you're
watching and I just wanted to begin by
showing you bit my office and explaining
what the periodic table means to
chemists like me you can imagine the
periodic table a bit like a family
photograph and just if you look at the
photograph taken it's a big wedding or
something like that there'll be some
people who know very well and others
where you can't include remembered what
their name is but you remember one or
two facts about them so if we begin over
here we've got a periodic table here
it's in French
slightly faded from the sunlight but
which has photographs of all the
elements and we'll be showing you some
of them now over here we've got a small
Russian one you can see here why is that
wonder event any relevance to you well
because my father came from Russia and I
like speaking Russian and it has all
sorts of complicated data on the back
this one here the area of the various
elements like hydrogen here and arsenic
there represents their relative
abundance on the Earth's surface then
over here I've just been given today a
Chinese one where you can see that the
elements they use the same symbols in
China as they do in the U in UK but we
have different obviously different text
and then over here are two more which
are really mad but I like having them
here because it confuses my students
sometimes when they need a bit of
cheering up there's this one which is
the periodic table of the vegetables and
then over here is the periodic table of
the desserts which has various puddings
and so on it which I didn't really
understand the symbolism of it at all
but it looks quite fun we use it really
quite a lot and I think that it's useful
because it reminds us about things and
looking at the periodic table over and
over again you discover new things and
it reminds you of relationships which
you might have forgotten so enough here
the last
thing around the room is this clock here
which has the first 24 elements so we
have the first 12 elements from hydrogen
to magnesium around the outside and for
those who like the 24-hour clock from
element 13 aluminium round to chromium
which is number 24 and it's really quite
difficult to take the tell the time it's
fun time my office so let's now get down
and look at the periodic table itself